la mañana de este sábado se llevó a cabo
la firma del segundo acuerdo parcial
para la protección social del pueblo
venezolano aquí en un hotel de la Ciudad
de México por un lado estuvieron
representantes del gobierno de Venezuela
encabezados por Jorge Rodríguez y por
otra parte estuvieron integrantes de la
plataforma unitaria De oposición
encabezados por Gerardo Blade este
documento básicamente consiste en la
Constitución de una mesa Nacional de
atención social que será un organismo
técnico auxiliar para cumplir con estos
objetivos y también se creará un grupo
especial de atención a los efectos del
sobre cumplimiento de las medidas
financieras internacionales en concreto
se definieron cinco acciones en materia
social
revitalizar el sistema de salud público
nacional
estabilizar el sistema eléctrico en
Venezuela ampliar el fondo mundial de
alimentos el programa mundial de
alimentos que ya se lleva a cabo del
país reforzar la infraestructura
educativa y atender los daños causados
por las torrenciales lluvias recientes
en esa nación Sudamericana Así mismo se
creará un fondo fiduciario único con
apoyo que se requerirá a las Naciones
Unidas es decir será un fondo que opere
con los lineamientos de la ONU y que
servirá precisamente para destinar
recursos para estos objetivos sociales
se planteó que se gestionara el
descongelamiento de los fondos de los
recursos venezolanos que están
congelados en las instituciones
financieras extranjeras previo al
acuerdo el canciller Marcelo ebrard dijo
que esto era un triunfo de la política
que representaba la esperanza para
América Latina y el representante del
reino de Noruega Dark neander dijo que
celebraban este estos avances y que
dependerá de la decisión y de la
voluntad de las partes que hasta ahora
han actuado con compromiso y prudencia